every morning the kitchens at this
georgian restaurant chain were into
action shashlik and freshly baked Hodja
puri cheesy doughy goodness or carefully
packaged up for delivery to to Moscow
hospitals all free of charge
I notice inertia freezing astonish
Buddha said he kissed me child cotton
with commanding motion firm watch the
urge Tata when you version chefs
especially me
mucho Mucho no way to attack my regime
in Moscow Russia spasiba
a lot of this is donated this chain one
of a growing list of restaurants which
never mind the pressures of lockdown are
queuing up to feed Moscow's hospital
staff and medics need all the fuel and
energy that they can get the virus came
late to Russia but it is definitely here
now cases are skyrocketing tripling in a
week with no sign that they're leveling
off most of them in Moscow but the
numbers are rising throughout this vast
country and that's despite three weeks
of lockdown the authorities have decided
to add grit to the message to stay home
introducing digital passes for all
travel riot police at checkpoints with
the military poised to step in but if
it's mass testing which is the key to
controlling the virus then Russia claims
it has carried out a massive two million
tests with half of those tested over the
last few days showing no symptoms
private clinics have taken on some of
the load testing people the state won't
who aren't in risk categories what would
you say the accuracy is it's about you
think well it's a question the regulator
says it's 98% but even the top covert
doctor in Moscow has said it's much
lower
the problems of there not being a free
press in Russia is that there is no
opportunity to interrogate the
powers-that-be
about what they tell you the numbers or
their strategy there is no daily press
conference as there is in the UK so it's
hard to tell whether they don't know the
numbers whether the numbers they're
giving you are true whether they're just
plucking them out of thin air a lot of
the time doctors are too busy or even
too scared to comment in his Easter
message a relaxed looking President
Putin was keen to give the impression
that all was in hand authorities on all
levels are functioning in a streamline
orderly manner and recognize the
responsibility before them the situation
is under total control as society as a
whole becomes united when confronted
with a common threat but there tends to
be a time lag between a spike in cases
and deaths it's too early to tell if
Russia will follow the German scenario
of mass testing low mortality rate or if
it will manage less well the covert 19
took awhile to get here
the Kremlin at least should have had
time to prepare down a Magna Sky News
Moscow